Hello,
I'm Zina Berdahl.
We welcome to the concert hall here in
Stockholm where this year's Nobel
laureates received their awards from His
Majesty,
the King of Sweden for the outstanding
contributions to literature,
economics,
and science.
This is the first time that they had
been brought together in discussion on
television.
And we're also joined in the audience by
some of their family and friends who've
traveled here to be with them as well as
students from Sweden.
Welcome to this year's Nobel mines,
Nobel laureates.
Welcome to you all and congratulations.
[inaudible]
you will one your Nobel prizes because
you know,
you are these very rational,
logical beings or you have great clarity
of thought in your novels and in your
economic work and so on.
So,
um,
do you really act very rationally with
weight logic in your personal lives of
John when you're nodding,
which has handwritten?
So yes,
you obviously do.
Yes,
I am.
I 100% rational,
but very,
very occasionally we have to step
outside that circle.
So the one little memory I have is a new
piece of equipment that was being
developed.
We only had access to it before atm.
I come in very early to try and use it.
Uh,
I couldn't get it to work.
I tried everything,
unplugged this sampling.
So eventually I said,
I'll just have to go home,
but I drive one final thing,
give it a kick.
He kicked it,
it sprang into life.
And there was a loose wire.
So that was my,
all right,
well let us see you.
I'm going to get around the tube,
you know,
and just get a quick quip from all of
you.
Think you're lagging,
frank.
Um,
I was,
uh,
in an earthquake in Pasadena in 1970.
Uh,
it happened at six o'clock.
I was asleep.
I went at immediate jump out of the bed
and went to the,
to the toilet and flush the toilet
immediately as it kind of reflex.
It's a reflex.
We won't go there.
Okay.
I can do both Shay and the third of the
chemistry lab,
we'll know the word falsification,
the creation of the rationality of a
scientific.
When you have a good idea,
you have to prove that it is wrong until
you have tried everything and then you
have proven the idea that I'm very
irrational.
I tried to show that my id is right and
sometimes push a bit too far.
Okay.
Thorn,
uh,
one of the physics laureates,
my greatest insights come in the middle
of the night and I'm sound asleep.
It's not rational.
I don't know how it happens,
but my mind somehow irrationally throws
things together.
I go write down notes in the bathroom,
make up the next morning and believe it
or not a third of the time.
It's good.
I have no idea where it came from.
That sounds,
yeah.
So serendipity I guess.
Yeah.
Ray,
vice,
you ever done anything completely crazy
irrational things?
I think the most important one was I
fell in love at night
teen when chasing a woman,
the Chicago,
and it was the end of me.
I flunked out and then I eventually got
back into that gallery it,
yes.
Back then might I flunked out of mit and
back after that I came to and I got a
job.
And that job made my career.
The education wasn't worth a damn.
Oh,
well we'll come back onto that kind of
theme later.
Barry Barish,
another of the physics lawyers,
I became a physicist and shuttle the
irrational way it was to decide not to
be a chemist,
not to be an engineer,
and not to be a writer.
In the last bluff was my freshman
physics class.
I'm going to jump out,
leave you out just for a moment because
I'm gonna come to you because we're
going to talk about your economic
theory.
But,
uh,
the medicine laureates might young.
Well,
so choosing to be a scientist is,
uh,
I won't say it's irrational,
but it does come with a lot of risk.
And I got lots of advice from people
that were close to me.
When am I going to get a job?
Uh,
uh,
when are you going to choose something
that,
uh,
it's understandable,
to the outside word world that has,
uh,
a simple track forward that you can be
sure to support yourself and such and
such a way.
So there's a very,
there's a very important component.
There's an emotional component.
And choosing to take risks and become a
scientist.
Michael Ross Fash so,
so I would say,
um,
in,
in order,
uh,
having a,
a,
a self destructive temper as a young
person,
it's not very rational.
Uh,
being a sports fan,
uh,
is not very rational.
And,
and then,
uh,
the concept of risk taking is,
is actually has,
it has a deep biological basis.
But of course people like taking risks
and a,
that has an upside of course is as Mike
mentioned,
but it's also a,
it also can be destructive.
You seem very benign now.
You've lost the temper.
Have you the self destructive 10.
I'm,
uh,
I'm most of the time under control
check,
progress work in regards their work in
progress.
What about pants and fellow to my right
and I worked together.
He's,
the name escapes me.
We,
we,
uh,
came up
a number of times with
labored pieces of poor royale public
behavior.
We thought our strengths were hilarious.
I'm not sure that everybody else in our
midst did do,
but we couldn't help her.
So,
oh,
right.
Okay.
Well,
can I see the sugar out literature
laureate?
Did you ever done anything?
I'm completely crazy that you look
crazy,
but I guess my wife and I,
we have a dodge connection is soft toys,
which we pretend still belong to our
daughter.
The daughter is 25 now I would have
voices for the mode and they have whole
kind of personal histories and the
relationships between them have
histories.
Uh,
I guess that's verging on the irrational
perhaps,
but I think it's perfectly reasonable.
All right.
Okay.
And when I brought out this odyssey fun,
irrational versus machinal behavior
because you,
Richard Thaler won the Nobel prize for
your work in behavioral economics,
which I'm really,
it says that,
you know,
mainstream economics didn't get it
right,
that people,
individuals,
households don't act in a rational way
when it comes to taking economic
decisions or indeed any other kinds of
decision.
So just explain to us,
give us an overview of what behavioral
economics actually is.
Well,
but he really cannot mix is just doing
economics that would accommodate all of
the stories that we've
just heard.
It was triggered by a dinner party where
an abode of cashew nuts.
Oh,
well,
yes,
I removed a bowl of cashew nuts that it,
uh,
was addicting a dinner party.
And,
um,
after I came back,
everyone thanked me for removing this
bowl of cashew nuts.
But then since it was a group of
economists B,
we began to wonder how it was that we
could be happy.
Since an axiom of economics is more
choices are always better than less.
So,
um,
yeah,
that was my apple.
Why did,
why did they thank you for removing the
bowl of cashew?
Because they didn't want to eat anymore
and they had plenty more color.
If the ball were there,
they would have continued.
I'm Richard.
I mean a lot of people focused on just
one component of your work could,
which is this concept of notch.
And you wrote a book of course with Cass
Sunstein called nudge and it's about how
people can be nudged into making better
decisions.
And David Cameron,
former British prime minister,
set up a nudge unit and indeed many,
many other countries,
um,
followed suit.
So it just gives us an idea how does
nudge actually work?
What does it try to set out to do?
Well,
a nudge takes into consideration what
our biases are and then tries to
introduce small features of the
environment that will adjust them.
So for example,
I'm supposed to,
we're worried that this show mike run
over.
Um,
then,
uh,
fortunately I set in my phone for the
amount of time we're supposed to do.
So when it starts beeping will note to
end and we won't worry about the risk of
running over.
I mean,
some people I get the message,
no,
I'm just trying to be,
it's a little nuts.
You can keep going.
It'll be beeping to nudge him.
You've advised governments on nudging,
you know,
trying to get policies that,
for instance,
we'll get young people like the students
we've got here in the audience to save
up for the old age pensions and to try
to get people to take decisions which
are in the self interest based on the
fact that people don't always do so.
Um,
but can we really leave it to
politicians and policy makers and their
advisors such as yourself,
to really nudge a person into,
into doing something like that mean
isn't it manipulation in some ways?
Well,
um,
the,
the real point is that we have no
choice.
So there's no alternative to nudging.
The only alternative is bad nudging
it.
Gentleman.
I mean,
what do you think about behavioral
economics and in particular this aspect
of it,
which is,
you know,
the concept of nudge with some of you
have liked to been nudged or have been
nudged into doing something that avoided
reckless behavior.
Yeah.
I want to nudge the society into
something different.
I wonder how you think about this.
I mean,
we teach the wrong kind of math to our
kids or you agree with that?
I mean,
for example,
if you want to nudge me into a certain
thing,
I'd like to know the art.
Right?
And we don't know how to make art in
high school or grade school.
I would teach it by having them gamble.
Yeah.
Right.
So that what people know deadly serious.
Well you want a nation of gamblers?
No,
that's not,
no,
no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Dahlia jumped too fast.
Don't do the first day.
No,
no.
The idea was to use as a mechanism to
learn the mathematics and the thinking
that goes with probabilistic reasoning.
Right.
Jeff Hall,
you are one of the three laureates for
the price in medicine or physiology and
talking about,
as I say,
you know,
the psychological aspects of economics
in behavioral economics and how the mind
works and the impact it might have on
economics.
But you,
you won your prize for,
uh,
what makes the body tick?
Um,
our body clock.
Jeff,
why don't you just perhaps spell out for
us what we mean by our body clock.
There are many kinds of revealed daily
rhythms that can be observed and
measured rhythms,
but there's longstanding information
from studying a whole variety of
different kinds of organisms that these
revealed rhythms are underpinned by
biological clocks.
Michael Ross,
Masha and Mike Young.
It's doing your research on,
on fruit flies.
We discovered that we have these body
clocks.
You know,
we're humans as well as all other
animals.
And you discover that by isolating genes
in,
in fruit flies.
In fact,
I think the fruit fly is featured in so
many Nobel prize experiments.
It deserves its own.
It's a little Nobel prize,
wouldn't you say?
Yeah.
A little teeny little thing.
Yes.
Mike Young,
once you discover the components of
these clocks,
you can look for them all over the
organism.
And as Jeff and his colleagues,
uh,
showed,
Andrew Sophala,
you find different parts of the work and
the fruit fly,
a fruit fly.
Yeah.
You've got,
you've got many different body parts
that display these rhythms using these
clocks.
So it's not just behavior,
it's many aspects of physiology.
The,
the other thing that became clear was
that you could start with the genes that
we found in the fruit fly.
And Lo and behold,
you have relatives in all the other
members of the animal kingdom,
including us.
So can we ask questions that would help
shift workers?
You know,
people who work in the emergency
services deal better with the kind of
work that they have to do at night.
Um,
can it help us understand why babies
don't sleep during the night?
I mean,
I always find that expression at all.
I sleep so well.
Just like a baby must've been said by
somebody who was never looked after a
baby because we know they don't sleep at
night.
Right.
So I mean,
you know,
does,
does your work help us understand these
common experiences?
Well,
in many cases what it reveals is there's
much more complexity to what's wrong or,
or,
or what we think we're observing when a
baby's not sleeping,
for example,
or take jet lag.
When,
uh,
we go from New York or Boston to,
to Stockholm,
what's really going on?
Most of us think,
well,
in a few days,
uh,
my one body clock,
we'll get the stock home and until then
I'm going to be in a state of malaise.
In fact,
what happens is that since you have
clocks all over your body,
there is disagreement that starts
occurring between the cells in different
parts of your body about what time of
day is it is.
And so in fact,
at the end of a flight from New York to
Stockholm for the next few days,
you're really occupying,
your body is occupying multiple time
zones simultaneously,
depending on which clock you look at.
Interesting.
Well,
I believe
your research says that there's good and
bad times during the day where,
where are we right now?
So it depends.
It depends on the,
there's there's times which,
which are more favorable for some things
than others.
Yeah.
So I think what you're alluding to
perhaps is this,
this is a very successful nap time for
exam,
for example.
For example,
especially for gentlemen or ladies our
age around,
around this table where in fact,
who were up late last night,
we were up very late last night was when
you received your awards,
do it all the festivities and,
and to an astronaut that has no
resetting mechanism,
well,
so aren't the cabins.
And My,
my impression was that the,
the,
the cabins have very intense light,
artificial light,
dark cycles to mimic,
to mimic the external environment.
Pretty primitive suicide.
Even if they didn't.
Yeah.
Even if they didn't,
if they weren't constant darkness,
they would show these rhythms and,
and that's fine.
In fact,
that's how they were originally revealed
in these models.
Let's see if we do often have,
the reality is that if you put an
organism into cycles that are different
from a day,
like seven hours,
seven hours,
yeah.
That certain organisms depending on the
organism can synchronize.
Yeah.
That's the old cult cycles.
But at some point,
you're so far away from 24 when you do
these tests,
they snap.
We know here in Sweden,
actually a lot of people do say they
have these lights that lumps,
that mimic daylight,
don't they?
Because they have such a dark days.
But this time with you,
but some of your colleagues working on
the body clock,
you've benefited from the work of our
chemistry,
uh,
laureates because of course some
gentleman you won your award for
developing a technique called Cryo em,
um,
which for the first time captured images
of molecules that were not visible using
standard techniques.
And of course,
we know that the world of molecules is
the core of what we call life.
So Richard Anderson in a nutshell,
what is Cryo em?
I think our,
our area of interest and expertise is
the easiest to explain.
In this group.
We basically freeze a thin film of the
molecules of life.
Take a picture of it and then you look
at the picture with your eyes.
It's magnified and you can see all the
molecules.
The computer helps you to interpret what
they are.
But the,
the methodologies are the tools that
were invented by,
uh,
the others particularly shock.
Duboce [inaudible].
All right,
well we'll go to shank dubois show then.
So this tool that enables you to look at
these molecules,
I mean its potential,
its possibilities of how it can help
human endeavor cure illnesses.
We are physicist,
we worked in
biology and we get the Nobel prize in
chemistry that confused people please.
He goes because we see atoms,
uh,
with the help of those people.
And when we see atoms we do chemistry.
And chemistry is a very powerful science
because if you have a biological object,
you see how the items are interacting,
one with the other.
You see how Alzheimer filaments are
attach to each other.
Perhaps you see a drug which will
separate the mall,
will prevent them to associate.
You will see anything with,
with,
with uh,
Kevin History.
It's an extraordinary power for method.
Yeah.
But I mean,
in the case of,
of,
you know,
what do you want your price for?
For instance,
in the case of the sea can fire is Cryo
e m was used to generate three d images
of the virus,
which meant researchers could try to
work out,
you know,
what kind of drugs would help to resist
the virus.
For instance.
I don't know if you want to pick that up
Joachim Front.
Yep.
Uh,
Zika is,
is a,
is a perfect illustration for,
uh,
did this combine a technology that is
now available.
So when we do know the structure of it
now,
it doesn't mean that we immediately find
a way of combating sees,
but,
but it makes it possible.
So the potential,
Richard Thaler.
Yeah.
I was just going to say that this links
up to the conversation we were having a
bit earlier,
which is,
um,
w whether choice architecture or nudging
is a good or bad,
it just depends on who's using it.
So all the scientists here have created
knowledge that can be used for good or
evil.
Um,
the s the same is true for a behavioral
science or behavioral economics.
Um,
and many companies nudge for evil.
last last night I toast was to nudge for
good and,
but that's a hope.
What you trying to send.
I mean all of you have worked,
you know,
for many,
many years on your endeavors.
And I think it was one chemist who said,
you know,
miracles sometimes the,
but you have to work terribly hard.
I mean,
is part and parcel of everything you do,
isn't it?
Failure is part and parcel of that,
that you'll carry out lots and lots of
experiments and expect many of them not
to succeed.
Yeah,
I think we are aiming to find out
completely you things.
So if when you're thinking of an
experiment in it,
in any area,
if the,
uh,
the choice that you make is close to the
knowledge that you have already,
then you're likely to have a successful
experiment.
But you want to have learned very much.
So if you make a bigger jump,
take a bigger risk and then most of the
time the experience when a feel,
but when it succeeds,
you make a bigger jump forward.
So I learned from,
uh,
Fred Sanger who had,
was,
uh,
had two Nobel prizes for his work in
sequencing protein and DNA.
He used to say,
uh,
that you should aim for a very high
failure rate.
My interpretation was 99% failure rate,
but the 1% that succeed takes you with a
very big step forward,
which is worth all the effort you've
spent or the other night.
I would say that
leaves out one,
one important component,
especially for young people who,
who like science.
And that is the discussion of,
of uh,
high risk,
high failure or very lofty goals,
leaves out an element of craftsmanship
to our profession.
In other words,
I think,
uh,
the,
the Chin with you,
the chance of,
of having tremendous success is,
is very small for anyone to individuals.
We are the,
we're the progeny that w we are the
beneficiaries of also a lot of luck as
well as hard work and perhaps a tiny
little bit of talent.
But the fact is that most of us here
love what we did.
And so that carries you through
failures.
Sure.
And you have to really like to do it.
But an interesting Michael all smash
because when you were young,
you were marked out as a potential
failure at school.
You were very unruly by your own
admission.
Okay.
You've known each other,
I know for many,
many years,
for 30 years,
but you also shocking to go,
I'll show,
you know,
you say that you were dyslexic at school
and Richard [inaudible],
you are mildly dyslexic.
I mean,
I think it's interesting that your paths
to this success now worrying about the
wrong thing.
It has been,
you know what,
I was just inspiring to people,
isn't it?
The list to Michael,
he said something very profound and that
is,
people like to work on things that are
fun,
that are a pleasure to work on.
That's absolutely fundamental.
None of us,
at least I certainly in my life,
didn't think I'm good.
My win,
the Nobel prize.
It was never in my mind.
It was not,
my life was not dedicated to winning a
prize.
My life was dedicated.
I enjoyed this thing I was working on.
Hey,
it was fun.
I,
my buddies with me,
we had a great time.
The whole project,
the Lego project isn't based on the fact
that they all look,
God,
we fail.
We fail.
No,
wait a minute.
Just listen to me.
I got to listen to me.
This is important because that just
stuck in that the,
you said it right and asking,
Oh,
oh God.
Failure,
failure,
failure.
That's not the way you think.
Yeah.
So the consequence is that you do things
which you get a kick out of.
And Luckily sometimes they turn out to
be important.
Bye.
[inaudible] you are they not done.
Brings
me to,
um,
Kazuo Ishiguro universally known as ish.
Um,
who won the Nobel Prize for literature.
And I know that in your writing career
you've had some false starts and works
that you've discarded and started all
over again.
Um,
but you know,
you are now amongst the giants of the
world of literature.
You've written eight novels.
And so when I see a lot of your,
your novel seem on the surface to be
quite different,
you know,
set in different countries and so on,
but there does seem to be a common
theme,
the relationship between the present and
the past,
would you say?
Yes,
the surface of my novel.
So kind of to set people think I keep
moving on.
Uh,
truth is I keep writing the same thing
over and over again and people don't
realize it because they have very
different settings.
But I think perhaps there is a parallel
between the kind of way I make progress
in the kind of way that the guys around
this table have done.
Um,
I,
I dig around some sort of piece of
ground.
Sometimes somebody comes up with an idea
or a topic that somewhere out there and
I think what that be great for somebody
else but it's not on this little thing.
Um,
I'm closing in on a,
um,
I'm digging away in the dead of night
looking expecting to sort of uncover
something strange down there.
You mentioned the scientists around the
table,
but you are interested in a discussion
about science and one of your most
famous books never let me go.
Um,
looks at um,
scientific advances,
um,
in a world that's kind of gone mad,
perhaps sat in,
in,
in the future where society expects that
all illnesses can be fixed and they
don't want to turn the clock back to,
you know,
people dying of cancer and so on.
It is that something that really
concerns you?
The misuse of science.
These are very important things I think
for books,
films,
plays to address,
but that isn't essentially what
literature is for.
It doesn't have to directly address
these questions.
I think what literature does is allow us
to understand each other across cultural
barriers,
linguistic barriers,
so that when we come to have the debates
about how we order our society,
what is important,
we understand how other people not
obviously like us feel most discoveries.
I think a two edged blades,
and this is at the heart of the Nobel
metaphase.
You like a man who invents dynamite,
which can do great things and very
destructive things.
We have to have a debate in society.
We have to think about what we do with
the great breakthroughs in the site of
guys around the table.
The other way to make sure that what we
do is understood enough by the public.
It doesn't have to be exactly what we,
you know,
this
famous problem.
It was this,
a CP snow made such a fuss over and I
think he had did a lot of damage with
that is the this cross fertilization of
people do science people who do music,
people who do arts.
That's got TIPCO and it isn't that,
I mean,
I'd like to have,
for example,
if in our country right now I'd like to
have the arts be able to know a little
more science,
very bearish.
I know you're a great fan of Kazuo
Ishiguro rose work.
What do you think about this
conversation between science and art?
You want it to be a novelist,
didn't you?
Yeah,
I mean I think what I mean,
as I said,
I eliminated several professions and
ended up in physics.
The earliest one was being a writer
because I read all the time when I was a
kid.
If you write a novel and it's read by
100,000
readers,
you're really writing 100,000
novels.
That's why there's book clubs because
it's not that anybody,
the guy next to you doesn't read well.
It's the how that novel,
this interpreted by them is different
than how you interpret the novel.
So it's a fantastic thing that you can
write something that actually is 100,000
stories I think.
And why the movies never as good as the
book because the movie does too much.
She doesn't really have the same
partnership.
That's my view.
Mm.
Did you like the movie of your book?
Never let me go.
Yes.
And I loved the movie of the remains of
the day.
I don't myself make a huge,
I don't disagree with you,
but,
um,
uh,
you know,
I,
I think all the art forms have their
special powers.
Yeah,
sure.
There are things that I can't do that
the filmmakers can do very,
very well and vice versa.
I just go to you.
I can frank,
because I know that you are a writer.
You've written short stories which have
been published and you have a novel
which has been unpublished about and
astro physicist at a university,
um,
that it might get published now that you
are an Obama,
you know,
any publishers listening unless you've
known.
Yeah.
Thanks for the plug.
A,
well,
for me,
uh,
the English language,
became a medium of re inventing by
itself.
Uh,
three,
uh,
I mean it was a very challenging thing.
And,
and when I discovered that I could write
dialogue and cut something across a,
it was an incredible experience to me.
I'm,
I'm saying it's sort of daunted by the
idea.
I'm sitting next to it in the literature
and talking about my little little
production.
Oh,
well why don't,
well,
one small point about that.
Certainly in the interest of young
scientists,
which is,
uh,
I think a lot of young scientists don't
pay any attention to the writing.
I don't mean writing a novel.
Um,
when you do research,
the end product is something written
and until you've written it down,
you haven't done anything.
Uh,
that,
that kind of says to me as well very
much,
but you just sick as somebody from the
world of the arts,
there seems to be some sort of
disconnect with,
with your great discoveries and your
breakthroughs and,
and then what the rest of society gets
preoccupied about.
And in popular culture and popular
debate,
it seems to me we're the world,
the Western world anyway,
very well prepared for a Zombie attack
on our major cities.
But we don't seem to be addressing,
uh,
you know,
how we reorganize our society as a
result of some of the staggering
breakthrough started being made in
science and technology.
[inaudible]
one to take two aspect of science,
which really has captured the public
imagination.
Popular Imagination of course,
is the world of science fiction.
Um,
I'll come to the physics lawyers because
you won your prize for the observation
of gravitational waves.
It was the first time that a passing
gravitational wave has been observed
directly on earth that you know,
huge scientific sensation.
So,
um,
kip Thorne,
why don't you just encapsulate for us
what this was all about?
So the black hole is something that
every child knows from comic books,
but a black hole is a spherical hole in
space that has such intense gravity that
nothing can get out and not even light.
And what we discovered was that 1.3
billion years ago in a galaxy far,
far away,
two black holes circled around and
around each other,
spiraling together.
As they emitted these gravitational
waves losing energy to the gravitational
waves,
the holes came crashing together at half
the speed of light,
and they created a veritable storm in
the shape of space.
And time,
time slow down and sped up oscillated
wildly.
If you can imagine time,
they're speeding up.
And slowing down relative to how time
flows here and that process produced
these waves and which space is stretched
and squeeze,
stretched and squeezed.
The traveled across interstellar space,
intergalactic space to the earth and
were captured by the,
or monitored by the instruments were
built by the experimental team that I'm
associated with.
This is a whole new way to study the
university study aspects of the universe
that we've never seen before.
It's a way by which we will in due
course watch the birth of the universe
and for the first time really come to
understand through recombination of this
with the theory,
the birth of the universe,
ray and Barry,
I mean,
what kind of,
it's a window on the world on,
on our universe.
What kinds of things might we discover
about our universe that we don't know
now,
Barry,
we've worked for decades developing an
instrument,
much likelihood the chemists talk about
this.
Just astounding.
I mean,
I can't imagine that we could do what we
could do except that we learn very early
that you couldn't prove that we couldn't
do it.
So we kept making steps and as I think
ray said earlier,
people keep asking us,
how could we stay at this so long
persistence.
No,
it was really a lot of fun because we've
broken new ground all the time,
much as you have without maybe making it
a discovery,
but just to experimentally go further
than people have before.
Black coal was the cause and really are
very much the stuff of science fiction
films.
Kip Thorne,
you a scientific advisor and executive
producer of one such film,
interstellar,
how important is it for you?
Do you think that science fiction should
actually be pays based on fact?
There's no necessity.
There are different genres of science
fiction and my partner in Hollywood,
Lynda obst,
who together with me wrote the treatment
from which interstellar sprang.
She calls this science faction icon
[inaudible] science fantasy.
Harry Potter is science fantasy,
interstellar science faction.
But the beauty of this for me is that a
film like this where the science is
embedded in right from the beginning,
uh,
it's capable of inspiring people about
science.
How else could I as a professor succeed
in providing some inspiration?
For 100 million people except for road
blockbuster film.
Like this
one.
One particular thing that you know a lot
of people sort of you like to know about
in science fiction so on is are there
other universes out there?
Parallel universes?
I mean it could your work in any way
help us discover whether there are
indeed other universities,
barry?
Well it,
it might,
there's different ways.
If we had an easy and straight forward
test to see if there was this idea was
right,
we'd probably be going after it.
There's various ways that we might get
clues,
whether it's right and some of them are
through the kind of work we're doing.
It's not very direct.
It's one of the ideas that kind of
springs from what we don't know about
the early universe.
So discussing here,
you know the success of films like
interstellar and science fiction to
contradictions there you might say,
I mean how important it sort of just
thinking about this,
this unit in general terms,
do you think that evidence based
discourse is in our societies today?
Let me get a view from all of you on
this.
Particularly as you,
perhaps you first jeff or people don't
know much about science and technology,
the electricity,
a miracle,
for example,
day to day things that never existed
Dick centuries ago.
And now we're taking for granted the
proper American in the United States is
not only ignorant but is actively
belligerently pugnacious Lee ignorance.
I refuse
go away or I'm secular humanist before
who thinks that they're all of these
irrational influences and that you will
seek the triumph of reason in the face
of all this.
Um,
Michael Ross Bash.
A lot of this has to do with,
with educational landscape because we,
we,
we've seen circumstances,
Eh,
most starkly in the u s but,
but in western Europe as well,
where politicians,
ambitious people take advantage of,
of,
uh,
the situation to exploit for their own
benefit,
for power gaining power.
It's,
it's not something that's unprecedented,
uh,
happened in the 20th century to
disastrous,
to disastrous ends.
And so it's,
it's a,
it's a very worrisome,
it's very worrisome concept.
Mike Hill,
you can have an attitude that you're not
interested in science and you don't,
can't benefit from science.
Uh,
these wouldn't exist if there hadn't
been discoveries 50 years ago that
invented the technology.
Uh,
if you,
uh,
just about every minute of the day,
everyone depends on some form of
technology so that the notion that it's
over or we have enough or uh,
it never happened or it never happened,
uh,
that this is brand new and created from
whole cloth is,
is such an incredible mistake.
Which a sailor,
we have a fact free administration in
the United States.
Um,
worrying about science.
It would be nice if,
um,
there was,
there were scientists and the
administration.
I would,
um,
subtle for some people who are
collecting facts.
Right.
But Barry is interesting.
I mean,
you know,
talk about it.
We've heard anti-science bias from,
from Jeff Wall for instance,
but your lego project,
um,
for the observation of these
gravitational waves,
did,
do you think that kind of support would
happen today for something like we did?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm worried not,
not,
you can't do science and move forward
without taking risks yet.
We have a system this become more and
more conservative.
I personally knowing the funding
situation pretty well.
And the u s through the National Science
Foundation don't believe that right now.
You could fund something that was
equivalent.
We as scientists have a job.
It's not just that we,
we have a job to make what we do more
intelligible
to people.
I think that that's why,
I mean kipps movie is an important
thing.
I think you also have to go and talk to
people who are not at college levels.
You have to talk to high school kids and
grade school kids.
Yeah,
I agree completely with,
with ray on this.
And I think the one key aspect I'd like
to emphasize is the importance that the
general public,
that the majority of the populace,
uh,
in a democracy particularly,
understands how science works,
understands its powers,
its limitations,
Jack to bullshit.
Uh,
the red mark by Mr.
Ashley.
She go home that it would be easy to
develop and make great a story about
zombies coming on us and destroy him.
Everything easy.
But why is it so difficult?
Why does it work to make a terrible
story about our climate going astray,
going about as bad as the Zombie beyond
earth.
Why can't we make a story of that?
Well,
you know,
I can frank or we talked before about,
uh,
the,
the difficulty of,
of,
of getting science even across to the
public and it,
that they are no existing forums and,
uh,
you know,
the problem is we have all these forums,
uh,
the media and the media,
you know,
chop everything into pieces,
Eh,
and,
and people are completely incapable of,
of getting some kind of a coherent story
out of this.
Richard Henderson do think that the role
of the scientist is to explain their
science to society,
but also beyond that to actually say we
want to raise the level of knowledge
based comments and debates and
completely with you on that.
Actually,
I think scientists are,
I am an optimist about this whole
discussion.
Uh,
I think scientists particularly have to
be optimists.
You couldn't have worked for 50 years
to,
to look for gravitational waves without
being an optimist to differentiate
between a rational,
irrational fact and fiction.
Better education,
I think is the answer actually.
And lots of people,
uh,
want better education for their
children.
Some of them take their children out of
school to give them a better education
of home.
Some people take them out of school to
avoid it.
Exactly.
So we need to improve the general when
doctor nate.
Yeah.
So that was nice.
Better education is the bottom line
correct?
You have in the past,
yes.
I mean you're just thinking with
scientists,
people to deal with facts,
but you're going to make a plea for also
fiction has a place in society.
Obviously we liked reading works of
fiction,
fiction culture.
I mean I think one of the issues is that
the business model behind the media and
journalism reporting is currently
broken.
The traditional ways in which newspapers
and periodicals use to spread knowledge
and debate and they were rewarded for by
and large for accuracy is gone.
Uh,
w what is important at the moment is
that it's eyeballs in it,
uh,
on websites clips.
You know,
there isn't a good economic,
economically viable business model,
uh,
by which,
we can have these debates,
uh,
because,
um,
people are driven by,
by the fact that you,
you have to get,
maximize the number of clips on the
website.
Right.
Well,
I hope you have fun.
Wow.
I hope you'll make an honorable
exception of this program at least,
and that you have had the chance to
interact with these great minds as well
as adding your great mind to our debate
here and our discussion.
I think everybody has found,
uh,
in the audience and beyond everything
that you've said really absolutely
fascinating.
I've certainly enjoyed talking to all of
you.
Thank you to all our Nobel laureates 'em
to our audience here in Stockholm at the
concert hall from me,
Xenapp Badawi in all of this on the no
bomb minds team.
Thank you very much indeed for watching.
Goodbye.